hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most incredible chess games that were
ever played uh it is of course Wei
versus Lazaro bruum Batista from the
highand djo grandmas Tournament of 2015
and uh a lot of you have been requesting
this especially since Wei won the Tata
still Master section in
2024 uh you you wanted to see way is
Immortal and this is not just an
immortal game this is also considered to
be one of the greatest games of the 21st
century uh not just by way but by anyone
uh so you guys will again have a chance
to to check it out and be the judge of
that because I have made a video on this
game some six years back but it's a very
short video 6 minutes and I pretty much
only show you the main line not all of
the secrets that the uh that the the
game U hides so we're going to enjoy
that as well and to give you a little
bit of background so it's like I said
it's The highand djo Grandmaster
Tournament of 2015 uh for we pretty
unremarkable event he won fourth place
Half Point behind ding Len who finished
third and he's playing against Cuban
Grandmaster Lazaro rusam Batista also
very very strong at that time he was
2600 but uh at some point he was like
2730 maybe 2725 so also an incredibly
strong player five times Cuban Champion
he was also a world junior champion in
in the year 2000 so incredibly solid
player and a very very strong so uh
let's check out the game and then we're
going to going to discuss a bit more Ki
with the white pieces opens with Pawn to
E4 and why this game is so requested we
have Pawn to C5 uh the Sicilian Defense
Knight F3 and pawn to E6 the singan
Sicilian and also one of the reasons why
this game is sometimes referred to as
havening and player's worst nightmare uh
we have Knight to C3 H and now a pawn to
A6 uh just preventing stuff from from
reaching that B5 Square we have Bishop
to E2 by way e and Knight to C6 we have
Pawn to D4 finally opening up the center
C captures Knight captures and queen to
C7 transposing into the floor variation
of the tonov we have castles and now
Knight to F6 the basto variation Bishop
to E3 and now Bishop to E7 so nothing
new here there are thousands of games
with this exact same position in the
database and there was also you know a
lot of theory uh about it in 2015 when
this game was played we have Pawn to F4
and now Pawn to D6 also interestingly uh
these are ratings from the time that the
game was played so even then we was
2724 uh you know for those of you who
are maybe new to chess are are not aware
of that uh King to H1 preparing to maybe
uh bring the bishop back to G1 if needed
for the moment okay the G Square the G4
square is covered by the bishop and
queen so you don't have to worry about
Knight G4 but it always makes sense to
move the king away from this diagonal to
avoid any future checks uh it it's just
a useful move uh we have Castle and now
Queen to E1 this is again very well
known and very useful the queen on light
squares doesn't really have all that
many uh possibilities but on the dark
squares the queen can go to F2 to G3 to
H4 and uh help out with the attack
against the black king here Lazar trades
off the pair of knights Knight captures
and D4 Bishop captures and pawn to B5
now preparing Pawn to B4 that's why the
most played move in this position is
Pawn to A3 stopping B before but here we
have Queen to G3 just bringing the Queen
into the attack uh and now Bishop to B7
now uh if you go B4 the idea behind B4
is E5 of course and it's uh if you're a
sicilian player you probably have uh
seen quite a lot of these B4 E5 Pawn
pushes where black has to decide whether
to trade which usually doesn't work out
all that great for black or you move the
Knight and then white gets the E4 Square
for this Knight so a possible variation
would be something like Knight E4 D
captures on E5 F captures now winning
the F6 and the D6 squares for your
knight if you need them and then just
Bishop to B7 and the game continues with
white always being a little bit better
because of um controlling more space but
all in all should be should be playable
for black uh however after Queen to G3
we have the immediate Bishop to B7 so
not forcing B3 and only Now Pawn to A3
uh Rook a to d8 and now Rook a to E1 we
have Rook to D7 preparing to double up
on the dile and the bishop to D3 now uh
the both Bishops are attacking the the
black king or you know mostly x-raying
the black king queen to d8 uh and now we
have Queen to H3 now if the pawn comes
to E5 for example captures captures the
Knight moves you get checkmated on H7 so
black has to be a little bit careful
here uh Pawn to G6 and now Pawn to F5
again doesn't look like much but uh
there's a lot of theory behind it and
all of it has been played before we have
Pawn to E5 uh Bishop back to E3 three
and now Rook to E8 and here way uh goes
for his first big think of the game and
on this move he thought about the
position for 3 32 minutes and he played
F captures on G6 now there are some
other games that reach this position for
example A4 is a know move Bishop to G5
is a know move A4 is in fact the top
move recommended by the engine uh but F
captures on G6 does appear to be the
most complicated uh move as after H
captures on G6 where ye plays Knight to
D5 and this is where the magic really
happens here uh the only way to deal
with this position without black losing
on the spot is to play Bishop captures
on D5 but it's um you know not a not a
move you want to make because you you
know that the E file will not the E file
the pawn from E4 will move at some point
and your Bishop will be a magnificent
attacking piece so of course you don't
want to give it up Knight captures on D5
was played in the game and now we went
into a an8 minute think and in that
those eight minutes he played Rook
captures on F7 you know upon uh
depleting those eight minutes and that's
the reason why Bishop captures was much
better so just to give you an example uh
instead of Knight captures Bishop
captures on D5 okay you can capture e
captures and now Rook to B7 uh and the
game continues but not nothing serious
here for example Queen F3 will put
pressure on F7 King G7 then Rook to f8
and it's perfectly uh fine position for
black H but instead Knight to D5 was
played and now Rook captures on F7 and
there's no option here whether you want
to capture or not otherwise Queen to H7
is Checkmate so The Rook has to be
captured and now comes Queen to H7 check
and the King hunt begins or rather way
Immortal King hunt uh what do you play
here King F6 or King T6 well let's check
and here pretty much after every move we
makes you can make it a pause the video
moment for yourself as there are so many
possible pause the video moments if if
you want to be a part of this game and
if you want to uh you know create this
masterpiece yourself uh you will you
know feel free to to pause it every time
black makes a move so here King to F6 uh
doesn't really work if you play King F6
then just e captur on D5 and uh how do
you stop Queen captur on G6 with
Checkmate uh well D4 you have to create
some room for the king but now Rook to
F1 check King E5 and queen captures and
G6 again threatening checkmates here
like Queen to E6 and if you play e
captures and D3 also Queen captures and
E4 will be checkmates so you have to
play something and now of course Queen
to F5 will be Checkmate so that's what
happens if you go to F6 so in the game
Lazaro played King to E6 but now e
captures on D5 and here again how do you
continue do you play uh King captures do
you play Bishop captures well if you
play Bishop captures then look at this
your king is basically uh in a in a two
tomb of black pieces that's uh I mean
when was the last time you saw something
like this and the the point now is that
after Bishop captur on G6 or maybe even
Queen to H3 check uh there's just not
all that much you can do this will be
Checkmate and how do you stop this uh
you can play Rook to f8 but it's
insufficient now Queen H3 check and
after King to F6 there's Rook to F1
check King G7 and now of course Queen to
H6 uh or better yet Queen to H7
Checkmate so what you could do after
this um Bishop captures on D5 move and
Bishop captures on G6 threatening
Checkmate is maybe just uh you know give
up the the bishop deliver a check but
even this is insufficient King captures
Pawn to D5 now you would very much love
to escape on the queen side but Queen to
F7 check King to D6 and now Queen
captures on E8 okay it's not Checkmate
but you're just um down too much
material that there's no way you can
play this captures captures white is
just up a full Bishop so instead after e
captures on D5 uh Lazaro continued the
the running away with the king king
captures on D5 was played and now we
have bshop to E4 with check and again uh
this is the only move that wins the game
for we it's such a beautiful move that
uh invites the king back to E6 but also
invites the king to E4 to face all sorts
of nasty discoveries and if you go to E6
then comes Queen captures on G6 and
after Bishop to F6 seems like you've
escaped Queen to F5 check King to F7
Queen to H7 with check King back to E6
and now Bishop to F5 with check forcing
the king back to D5 and after King to D5
now Bishop captures on D7 covering C6
and U uh E6 threatening Queen to D3
Checkmate so E4 stopping that and now
Queen H5 check King to C4 and now Queen
to E2 with check and that's pretty much
it King to D5 Queen to E2 uh Queen to D2
with check King to C4 and and B3 will be
a nice Checkmate so that's what happens
after this bishop captures an E4 move
happens if you play King to E6 so of
course in the game King captures an E4
was played and now uh there are there
are two winning lines here one is the
the line that way you played and the
other one is the line that you will find
once you pause the video because this is
what I really want you to find um in
this game even though all the moments
could have been paus the video moments
this is the one I want you to find feel
free to pause the video and try to find
a forced Checkmate in nine for we while
I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations and
spotting this uh literally unspotted
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Pawn to C4 this
is the move that even the great way
couldn't find in the game uh and the the
reason why it's so so strong is that um
well it just uh prevents uh uh it just
prevents the king from escaping to C6 or
C5 uh in some of the lines for example
Queen to F7 check if the king um gets to
D5 Queen to F7 check the King goes up
the board and then Queen captures and C4
would be Checkmate uh well it would be
if the pawn was not on B5 so by playing
C4 first and getting rid of the Pawn on
B5 you ensure that that's not happening
and if black doesn't capture well then
the D5 square is just covered and queen
captures and G6 will be Checkmate uh
that's the that's the whole point so
here the the point is if you go let's
say King to D3 uh then Queen captures
and G6 will be enough and there's really
not all that much you can do Bishop to
E4 Rook to D1 check King to C2 Queen
captures on e4 check and now a very
quick Checkmate Queen to D3 check King
to A2 and now Queen to C2 with Pawn to
B4 incoming doesn't really matter what
black does Pawn to B4 with check King
captures on A3 Queen to C3 check King A2
and Rook to A1 will be Checkmate or uh
if after this C4 move you play the you
go the other way around you actually
capture on C4 now the line that we've
discussed Queen captures on G6 King to
D5 and queen to F7 check and once the
king um goes uh uh well you could go to
C6 then Queen captures and C4 is
Checkmate that's the whole reason why we
played C4 so the B5 Pawn would not be
guarding the C4 square and queen Capt
and queen C4 or queen captures on C4
would be possible so you have to go King
to E4 now but now uh you could go uh
Bishop to B6 open up a discovery you
could go Bishop to G1 with check you
could play Queen captures and C4 so
everything works here King to F5 Rook to
F1 with check King to G6 and now Queen
to F7 will be Checkmate so that was in
the position uh after this um King
captures on e4 was played but we did not
find Pawn to C4 however he found the
other winning continuation he played
Queen to F7 right away also
congratulations if you found that one I
mean it is the still still very much a
winning move uh and now the threat is
Queen to F3 Checkmate so how do you stop
that Bishop to F6 only way to stop it to
block the White Queen now comes Bishop
to D2 with check forcing the the black
king to move and where do you move the
king well if you go to F5 which well
looks weird I mean the White Queen is on
on F7 uh then Rook to one check and
after King to G4 there's Queen captures
and G6 with check the bishop covers G5
so the black king cannot defend the pawn
and after Bishop G5 there's H3 check
King G3 and now Bishop to E1 with
Checkmate that's why the bishop is so
powerful on D2 it always has this
possibility of going to E1 so after
Bishop to D2 check King to D4 was played
and now Bishop to E3 with check again
the only winning move for we we have
King to E4 and now uh Queen to B E3 so
it is a repetition of moves but I'm I
guess we was just checking if the king
will come to F5 but since the king
remained here now it's time to find the
other move Queen to B3 with check and
this is the uh first uh later on when we
was giving an interview he said that he
didn't uh see all the way to Checkmate
when he sacrificed The Rook on F7 as it
was really complicated but he you know
figured out that he will be able to play
this uh but after playing Queen to B3 it
was already at this point that he had
the Checkmate calculated so King to F5
was played now comes Rook to F1 with
check again the only winning move and
now King to G4 and interestingly uh
again there is only one winning move
here uh feel free to pause the video for
the final time and win the game for way
while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on playing
one of the greatest games that was ever
played and winning it and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Queen to D3 the only winning move and
now uh what's what's the idea behind
this well uh if you give black a move
black will play King to H5 and G5 and
that will free up the H5 and G H6 and G6
squares for the black king and you will
be able to escape because you will
either be blocking this diagonal or this
diagonal once the the White Queen
finally comes to D3 however after Queen
to D3 right away it's impossible because
after King H5 there's Queen to D1 check
and now you can't go up the board you
have to go down the board and now Rook
to F3 uh one last sacrifice before
delivering Checkmate if you don't
capture Rook to H3 is M so Bishop
captures Queen captures but now there is
no no defense whatever black plays
literally any move black plays Queen to
H3 will be White's next move and it will
result in Checkmate so after Queen to D3
uh Lazaro played the only remaining idea
that prolongs the game and that is
Bishop captures on G2 with check and
again uh you can't just uh you know play
whatever uh sometimes when when you're
attacking you let's say you have little
time on the clock someone gives a check
you say I want your Bishop I'm just
going to play King G1 and then I'm going
to Checkmate you but if you played King
to G1 here now the game is actually
winning for black because after Bishop
G5 there's no way to hunt down the black
king queen to E2 with check King H4
Bishop to F2 check there's King H3 looks
impossible but it is uh possible Queen
to D3 check now King G4 and after Queen
to E2 with check there's even Bishop to
F3 and after H3 check you just play King
H5 you give up the bishop and after
Queen captures you just hide the King on
H6 and black is just up a full Rook uh
with white having no way to continue the
attack so it's important to play the
only winning move and that is King
captures on G2 even allowing this one
check on this long diagonal Queen to A8
check was played King to G1 and now
Bishop to G5 but now comes is uh perhaps
one of the most difficult moves to find
uh not maybe not the most difficult in
terms of uh you know calculating but
You' already had to play like 10 only
moves that win the game throughout the
entire attack and now you have to play
another one and there are many that look
great like Queen captures on G6 looks
great Queen to D1 check looks great but
if you played either of those uh you
would not be winning this game and I'm
going to briefly briefly explain why
because after Queen captures on G6
there's Rook G8 and now there's no way
for you to actually capture on G5 and if
H3 check King captures on H3 Queen F5
check H it's nothing more than a
Perpetual King to H2 and now after Queen
to H2 there's Bishop captures on E3 uh
and that's it Queen to H3 with check
King to G5 Queen captures an E3 check
King to G6 Queen to G3 with check and
with the rook and queen controlling the
fngg file the king will be safe on the H
file as there's a white King on H2 so
that's how you uh survive this and it's
uh I mean white is down a rook white has
to force a Perpetual Queen H4 check
Queen G4 check and just back and forth
so uh Queen captures on G6 will not do
if you go Queen to D1 with check again
it's not it doesn't work because after
King to H4 and Bishop to F2 check King
H3 uh there's a queen to D3 with check
and now there's no way to continue King
to G4 and now Queen to G3 check for
example King to F5 Queen H3 check King
to F6 and okay you can pick up the The
Rook here but now it's black to move and
there there's no way to do anything here
you can play Rook E7 you can play Bishop
to F4 there's no way for white to
actually win this game so not Queen
captures on G6 not Queen to D1 check the
correct move is Queen to E2 with check
and it looks bizarre why is this not
winning and why is this winning well
there's a very very uh particular idea
after Queen to E2 with check King to H4
Bishop to F2 check King to H3 now comes
the move that was not possible if your
queen was on D1 and that is the final
move that we plays in this game and that
is Bishop back to E1 absolutely
Sensational stuff uh he was in this
position un move 36 that Lazaro Bron
Batista resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so the
problem with the queen being on D1 and
you playing Bishop to E1 is that Queen
to G2 would just be Checkmate so you
need your queen here to stop Checkmate
and now
uh black can give a few checks but
that's pretty much it you can go you
know zigzag with the queen to deliver a
few checks Queen A7 check King to H1
Queen to B7 with check you're going to
block with Rook to F3 block check by
delivering check and after King to G4 we
get this position where okay The Rook
cannot move because it's pinned by both
of the Queens uh and now after Queen to
G2 with check King to H5 there's finally
Rook to H3 check you don't care about
winning the Queen H because after a Bop
to H4 Rook captures on H4 will just be
Checkmate so uh that's that's the one
that's way e mortal game that's one of
the greatest games that was played in
the 21st century uh hope you guys hope
you guys enjoyed it and uh yeah now you
see the now you see the difference
because every now and then you know
every month or so someone will post a
video saying okay this is an immortal
game no it's not this is an immortal
game this is an immortal game where you
don't have a way out there was never a
way out from that moment where Knight
captures on D5 was played the the you
know Rook captures on F7 started
something started an avalanche of moves
that could not be stopped and way uh
just you know rode it to to Perfection
and U you know this masterpiece was
created so uh at the time that I covered
this game some six years ago I only
covered the main line so it didn't
really you know uh uh look look like
much uh but yeah if you if you want to
see the difference also check out that
video will be the first link in the
description below yeah incredible stuff
by way hope you enjoyed this Immortal
game and maybe if you're new to CH now
you know what an immortal game really is
not you know everything's everyone
saying this is an immortal this is an
immortal yeah it's not this is an
immortal game uh so I hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank ala s please
Samuel Kane Gard enlan Jeremy antios and
David gasparian for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh you know so stay
tuned for that uh I I believe I will
show two more wi games that I'm pretty
sure you guys will really love uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day